what's your strategy to win big brother
canada
my strategy to win big brother canada um
be trustworthy be authentic uh be open
to collaborations be open-minded just in
general never pass up an on an
opportunity i think when the opportunity
the whole kyle moore thing came around i
jumped on that i think i've got a pretty
good eye for when a good opportunity
comes around and i'm just not going to
close myself off from any part of the
game
perfect uh what kind of personality will
you apply for in the house
i think i'm going to clash in the house
in the house i think i'm gonna class
with somebody who's just like that that
loud big like
i don't want to say necessarily
overconfident because i'm a confident
guy but somebody who like you know
really exudes that like i'm superior um
that kind of uh
that kind of mentality just doesn't
doesn't vibe with me
[Music]
uh
showmans are no man nomads no
no listen okay i get it you know and and
i'm a 23 year old guy single
you know i love women i think that uh
you know and and you know being able to
um
talk openly and just like get to know
somebody on that level it's just and
granted you have an amazing opportunity
in the house and i can see why close
relationships come out of an experience
like this but it's just not it's not
part of my game right now i'm already a
threat i am i'm big i'm i'm strong i'm
you know socially very uh very uh adept
i don't need another uh target on my
back in terms of like oh we gotta break
up the you know the showmance it's it's
not my thing a flirtmance maybe we'll
see what happens depending on who's in
the house if somebody if i vibe with
somebody and it happens it happens but
in terms of showmance absolutely not you
can book that too like i'm it's not
gonna happen
a lot of people say that i'm sure they
have i mean it i've been doing this for
10 years
yeah listen hey i know that uh you know
jet and death probably sat here last
year and we're like no what there's not
a chance in hell but uh but yeah no this
is this is like i'm
there's literally no i don't care if
like the most beautiful one i've ever
seen walks through that door there's no
chance i'm getting in a showmax with
that one no chance
hey
we'll talk
uh why is canada gonna leave for you
why is canada gonna root for me this
year i mean they rooted for me before i
was even a house guest so the idea of
actually being on the house i hope that
carries over um i just hope that canada
sees the values in me that they want to
see themselves you know somebody who
just like loves people and um
yeah i just i just hope that every
canadian can see a little bit of
themselves in me
and uh and if that gives them a chance
you know to be a lightning rod for hope
and uh you know lightning rod for belief
because if you can believe in me i
guarantee you you can believe in
yourself um so if that's the uh if
that's the case i think i think kendall
liked me
so last year i was mistaken for the kyle
moore who was a big brother canada
season nine and uh
now i'm here so
something worked out
you